abortions up until 20 weeks
taxpayer-funded is a bipartisan issue
well you might have a justice who
disagrees oh my god this is awesome so
before we move on to this is my question
do you really think at this point that
it's both sides polarizing equally is
that just a cop-out I contend it really
pretty much exists exclusively on the
left that calls to violent action on a
massive scale and if I really think it's
a cop out when they talk about how
polarize we are as a country and act as
though both sides contribute to it
equally I don't agree with it comment
I'd like to see what you have to say so
Justice Kennedy retiring and so that
means that President Trump is gonna
block down a conservative Supreme Court
majority so here's the thing that in in
the past weeks we've talked about this
kind of polarization you don't have
disagree to it on this big chasm between
the left and the right the right
accomplishes there wins through to
freedom by the way or proper political
channel channels as you see within the
Constitution so let's kind of dance with
them for a while they've embraced
outright harassment and violence that
they pretty just flirted with you've all
seen the Maxine Waters who basically
endorsed harassing the political
opposition let's see the clip
[Music]
[Applause]
but speak for yourself a black lady
making sure to tell in for people yeah
what I want you to do is get a mob now
once you tell them day welcome then get
the German shepherds and the fowls yes
plan a Widow's of PAS to your tart at
this diner top hit the notification Bell
case you have it on YouTube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot or
the bookmark because notifications are
going away so here the Supreme Court
rulings that are having the left lose
their complete minds the big one on
labor unions today's Supreme Court ruled
in favor of public sector employee who
refused to join a public union so
basically all this says is you can't
mandate union dues for federal employees
yeah they were taking it out as a kind
of a Fair Pay deal so if they got a
contract for either saying this is an
administrative fee and we know money's
fungible and say we're just using it to
support their leftist ideology anyway
what is it and they're saying I don't
want to do an elective this is a giant
blow for workers choice what for your
chair choosing to not they are choosing
to not join the deserved blow to
terrible unions what by you're saying
people can join the union yeah
originally it wasn't mandatory people
joined because I wanted to now there are
so many people who do not want to be a
part of the Union that they take this to
the Supreme Court because they don't
want to pay their dues and unions want
to force not only fortune to pay dues
but then also force them to publicly
reveal their voting with card check so
this is one this is a big win for choice
I don't know what you want the unions
know what you want they know best yeah
if you're on the other side of this one
go to a different country and then
crisis pregnancy centers yesterday
Supreme Court ruled against the law that
Forrest pro-life pregnancy centers to
advertise abortions or to advertise
other people who provided abortion
services and then of course there was a
Supreme Court upheld Donald Trump's
travel ban so these are a big these are
big wins for choice for freedom your
unions can't force you to give to an
organization that would send money
straight to Democrats by the way labor
union we've talked about this you look
the top political donors of all time
yeah the cup frozen look at the union
that's not even close you wanna talk
about who pulls strings just run
quick search of all time right and the
left considers these failures yeah the
pro-choice left unless it's choosing at
the join a union
pro-choice unless it's choosing to run a
pro-life organization they hate choice
but Italy when it comes to speech and
I'll get to that in one second I think
they just need to be honest about it
they don't like what this country is
founded upon they want something
completely different and that's fine
just go do it somewhere else
all right I don't want you here doing it
here and saying that you love America
the way I love America because you're
not you're not being honest no you're
not being honest about and spend
computers and you have a yet a pointer
from the New York Times yeah so the New
York Times came out and they had an
opinion piece in the tree about PP been
said that you know there you can see
right here that the 5-4 majority and
that the Supreme Court is invoking legal
rules and that is pretty much
discriminatory which is amazing
say you know how dare they a court
invoke legal nerve yeah legal rules like
the other maybe get this
[Applause]
yeah yes pretty evil that's it what the
carts are for so and this is a big
difference when you look at the mob rule
from the left so right after the school
shooting right by the way it's gonna be
a whole lot harder now with the course
if you want to pass some kind of gun
control look behind you
that was your best chance you so
parkland what to do they trot out kids
and CNN to chew out Dana lash in the NRA
what do we do we win elections and
here's the aunt of attacked exert their
they never really went away but now
they're just so open about it in the
mainstream
it's our distinguish it's no longer
masked activists harassing you know Lane
child it's just a group of teenagers who
just have been inspired by Maxine Waters
I guess
there you go why is separating families
why I separated work probably sleeps at
night with his kids in his house because
I didn't come here illegally oh here's
the thing I could call someone or not
yes that they didn't they realize didn't
work because people become desensitized
it's similar so now interview why are
you separating children these are texts
that you see when you dehumanize your
opposition it's okay it's okay to
threaten to firebomb their bed it's okay
to threaten to slash their tires and you
see these anti style tactics by the way
outside of the aunt of an organization
which you know Han did not get a knife
personally to stab conservative
protesters that's here on the channel
you see what Sarah Huckabee Sanders the
restaurant debacle this is a cultural
censorship that it's a cultural Marxism
or they want to intimidate harass and
violate your actual rights not imaginary
rights like health care being a human
right no it's not but my right to not be
physically assaulted in the real world
that's not it's not a safe space that's
not have snowflake that's not a trigger
I don't want to be shot with a 45 I
think that's reasonable they tried to
re-appropriate triggering Marilyn so
weird what are you triggered oh yeah
fire bombed you see what happens when
you don't take your meds they see this
is entirely along with calling for the
complete abolishment of ice that's their
pivot I think we've come to a moment
where we need we need to call for the
abolishment of ice I think I should be
abolished in order for us to feel safer
in our streets our churches our schools
and our homes we must abolish ice this
is the legislation that we need versus
this is the legislation that is going to
move us forward as a country should be a
bipartisan issue it's textbook
government waste we spend more than six
billion dollars a year on this bloated
unaccountable cruel to
apartment I just love that when they say
it should be but abolishing any
Charlotte border security should be
agreed-upon across the board think never
having a forcing Michaels forcing Hobby
Lobby provide for more forms of borås
control in addition to the 16th note
apparently provided but they don't
private because I think this should have
bipartisan support no no you crazy
absolute which it shouldn't be this is
by the way another reason for the
Crowder confront series that we do these
attacks are so mainstream it's not just
fringe and it's gonna get a lot worse
now that Justice Kennedy is is stepping
down that's what yeah we have more of
these crowded confronts it this is this
is one thing we're talking about this
with Crowder confronts that we did we
went in there girl threatening to
firebomb by the way works it works at UT
hears that you're in the crazy thing
when you talk about this and they're
gonna say oh you're not trying to Doc's
anybody here but someone saying hey
here's their location here's a picture
take care of this with a bomb and our
van and then doubling down take care of
it someone plotting to hurt people in my
crew people plotting to shoot us people
plotting to slash tires where it's take
your pick on that given day right
Molotov cocktail this has been happening
with us for a while how many people do
you think that this poor Charles Hermes
who spread the fake Nazi memes how many
kids do you think got the night at the
UT Registrar's because this broad had an
opinion yeah Lots it's not just about
shouting down some on the street but
you're just saying they literally think
you're separating children that you hate
children and you hate parents they
literally what do they think it or not
it I've just convinced themselves or at
some point someone's getting convinced
that I'm a Nazi and ben shapiro with the
yarmulke
is a nazi these people are getting
convinced and what are you if you saw
nazi today right if you saw nazi today
out there who was actively rounding up
Jews and gassing them you'd probably do
something if you're a decent human being
but that's what they say we are and so
what does it get him it makes it
completely morally morally justifiable
and that's why we're at the point you're
with the left I've never wished violence
on anyone on the left and III wouldn't
today
even these people who have issued these
threats I don't think anyone on the
right should go out and violently accost
the left I don't want you to only in
self-defense let me make it really clear
self-defense with me if they physically
attack you first to protect yourself or
your fam
that is all I am saying okay I'm not
calling acts of violence but you do need
to start confronting these people
because we are at the point when I
notice what the left we were there not a
single person condemned it I genuinely
thought we were one step away from if
the cops had come in grabbed us and said
there we're gonna take them out to the
firing squad any anyone have any
objections they would have cheered
because yeah humming aha mana Nazi and
if it weren't for the security in the
cops that were there I think it would've
been much worse scenario I think they
were I probably would have been much
more changed than they were yeah I think
I think you're peeling it back to like
you and I have had arguments not
arguments but we've had discussions
about this and I'm thinking our you know
we need to try to find some common
ground you're like you asked me some
very simple questions do you believe
this do you believe that do you believe
this yes I do well they don't know they
don't the thing and and their ideas have
stopped working and when you get to the
end of your ideas the only thing you
have left is violence and intimidation
tactics and that's exactly where they
are they should be able to see that
that's what they're accusing us look a
lot of these look at the crazy outrage
over the fact that Kennedy's retiring
yeah nothing's even happened yet you're
saying it's the end of American by the
way the end of America is there oh god
they could enforce the law now we
abortions up until 20 weeks
taxpayer-funded is a bipartisan issue
well you might have a justice who
disagrees oh my god this is awesome
all over again I think I'm to invoke the
legal rules BP are they going to like
what is this a gleep
oh you're one of those legal courts it
is the law huh
I really and this is why I think it's
disingenuous you have some people look
let's find common ground listen we do to
change my mind segment and a lot of
these by the way credit confront stem
from people trying to harm us while
doing change my mind so when we sit and
we say anyone can have a conversation
all right listen
hey Kennedy one I'm gonna laugh I think
it's great I think it's fantastic the
right is winning so much it's solar I
need to I need to get a bomb because of
all the winning it burns but you're
you're able to sit down and have a
conversation when you decide that you
are going to threaten us when you are
going to stifle the conversation through
acts of violence
that's where Crowder confronts comes up
and that's what I think is happening
with the right if they are saying all
right listen we have tried to actually
have a conversation not common ground
but a conversation you can have a
conversation and not have any common
ground because truth is the truth I tend
to believe the truth lines up on the
right right that's system I believe I
did I don't believe the truth to
centrist I don't believe that taking
another life
is the is the right there I believe it's
it's immoral I believe it's a lie to say
that it's not a life I don't believe
that it's okay to declare anything you
want to be human right I don't believe
that it's okay to commit violence
against political opposition just
because of a different opinion these are
things that line up on the left I think
that's wrong the truth is those things
are wrong the very very they're very
very bad but this is how bad it's
getting out there and I think it's time
for people to stop being disingenuous
claiming that both sides are at fault no
they're not make sure here's the thing
they try to point to some right way they
go what about the Nazi the tiki torches
first off they were National Socialists
whoever actually watched their speeches
their speeches are we can make socialism
work if it weren't for blacks and browns
they don't want Liberty they don't want
the current constitutional conservatism
they want socialism that they would see
in Norway for only white people these
people are not right-wing okay
and you surely can't find any mass
organizations on the right you can look
at statistics to let the leftist
organizations and gatherings whether
it's Occupy Wall Street whether it's the
women's marches whether it's antiphon
or just going back to Woodstock where
people are getting raped and looting
ATMs okay
Nazis are just nuts as your socialists
plus racism that's all it is now social
just add racism like the expanding
dinosaur you come back and like that's a
concentration camp coming from Mars more
stars on Yelp it just took an angry man
no more coming up just finding truth and
the left is acting out and I do think
final point I think Donald Trump is
becoming more conservatives we talked
about this I don't think he was
conservative what do you and present we
talk because he was registered as a
Democrat I think he was much more of a
centrist and I think he's going through
the same process as people are watching
it I think what's happened is he went in
as a centrist and the left has forced
him to loathe them I don't think that
all Trump was ready to be called a Nazi
I don't think he was aware that they
were going to call him a racist I don't
think it was where they're gonna go
after his his his kids his family I
don't think he was aware of that and so
people watching this you're seeing
people on YouTube you're seeing people
online you're seeing people just sort of
in the in the cult in the zeitgeist as
the term is used becoming more
conservative being read pilled i think
that's happening before our very eyes
with donald trump think he's going to
okay all right good copy of that see
screw you when he's just doubling down
and
think it's great gosh the winning it's
starting the starting up I mean it's
getting to the point of being a nuisance
subscribe watch one of these other
videos or hit the notification Bell well
you should hit that if you subscribe
anyways because subscriptions don't mean
anything on YouTube anymore now you have
to get notifications and it shows up in
your inbox so I don't know why you
subscribe in the first place but that's
we have to do also making money off
these videos anymore because YouTube
decided why they just said we're not
going to and when we said why they
didn't tell us why exactly imagine if
you showed up to your job to do your
work and then they said hey by the way
we're not gonna pay you said why they
said piss off